What I eat in a day as a 22 year old tribewife.
So first off, I start the day on an empty stomach with some tincture.
Then I'm gonna have my raw milk protein shake.
I'm using just ingredients.
Chai Protein powder is one of my current favorites.
Then I'm gonna take my supplements.
I've got some freeze dried bananas to take them with
because I cannot swallow pills.
Then at lunchtime, I'm gonna make my just ingredients electrolyte drink.
And then I'm gonna eat some tuna salad wrap with fresh tomatoes.
I tried to wrap it and I warmed up my tortillas too much,
so they just broke.
I'm gonna have some ranch cottage cheese and carrots.
And then for supper, I'm having sourdough buns with barbecue beef,
some potato salad and cauliflower.
And then for dessert, I'm gonna have some leftover strawberry cobbler.
That did not turn out like cobbler,
but hey, it was still good.